LAURA LING: These trucks,
filled with 14 tons
of perfectly good food,
would have normally gone
straight to the dump.
But this time, they didn't.
KOMAL AHMAD: We partnered with
Super Bowl 50 and the NFL.
We recovered 14 tons of food.
And to put that in
perspective, that's
four 16-foot refrigerated trucks
filled to their absolute brim
with high quality food that fed
over 23,000 people in just two
days.
LAURA LING: At
just 22 years old,
Komal Ahmad set out
to create an app
called Copia, which connects
businesses with excess food
to communities in need.
KOMAL AHMAD: Just
as easily as you
can use your phone to swipe
right or request an Uber,
you could use that same
piece of technology
and know for 100% fact
that that food is actually
going to be consumed by
people who are in need.
Copia operates in the
San Francisco Bay Area.
Businesses sign up with
the app, and within minutes
of a request, Copia will be
there to take perishable food
to people in need.
It can range from stadiums,
arenas, grocery stores,
catering companies, anyone with
surplus, large volume of food.
Will pick it up.
We will provide
data and analytics
on how to reduce that
waste in the future.
And we will also
directly connect it
to the nonprofits that are in
need at that day at that time
and can use that exact
quantity of food.
LAURA LING: Copia's
drivers, called food heroes,
transport and
distribute the food
to nonprofits around the city.
On any given day, how much food
would you say you're saving?
And how many people
are benefiting?
KOMAL AHMAD: On a weekly
basis, we are feeding well
over 10,000 people a week.
LAURA LING: So there's brown
rice, broccoli, spare ribs,
mushrooms, romaine salad.
There is a lot of food here.
And this is just
from one company.
It's crazy to think that
this all might have gone
into the trash, been dumped.
But not today,
because this is going
to be delivered to about
three different organizations
to people who are hungry, who
could really benefit from it.
Copia is just one
of countless groups
trying to eliminate food waste.
But technology could be
the much needed component
to accelerate the movement.
It is astounding to me knowing
that over 133 billion pounds
of food goes to
waste every year.
Do you think hunger
can be eliminated?
KOMAL AHMAD: Absolutely.
Hunger in America is definitely
not an issue of scarcity.
It's an issue of logistics.
We waste three
times as much food
as there are mouths to feed.
LAURA LING: Copia charges
businesses a small fee
per pound of donated food.
In turn, companies can claim
a tax deductible right off.
Komal hopes that this will be
an incentive for more companies
to get involved.
Copia is a for profit entity.
Why did you decide to structure
it that way, as opposed
to a nonprofit?
KOMAL AHMAD: We decided to
be for profit for scale.
We want to solve this problem.
And we think it's a
better use of resources.
Instead of just trying
to do it small scale
in specific communities, we've
received over 60,000 requests
for global expansion.
So from senior
government officials
in Germany and Austria who
say, we want this technology,
we want to help
you expand, to help
redistribute food
and other resources
to the Syrian migrants.
And that's just one
really exciting case.
LAURA LING: How has technology
been a game changer?
LAURA LING: I
think by and large,
for the first time
in human history,
we can solve some of the
world's largest problems.
And with technology, it's better
and faster than ever before.
We're moving perishable
food, and we're
trying to move it as quickly
and as safely as possible.
So that's where
technology really helps
to connect the moving pieces.
LAURA LING: On another
episode of "Seeker--"
INTERVIEWER: Not that
long ago, environmentalism
was a fairly bipartisan issue.
But all that changed.
And it might be because
of this guy and this guy.